hey folks i'm pumped about this today on
mondays with monica i'm talking to the
legendary the iconic
mr lou gossett jr at 85 years old y'all
he just had a birthday he's had a
storied career that began back when he
was in high school
now gossip went on to win an emmy for
his role in fiddler in roots remember
that back in 1977
he's also known for playing gunnery
sergeant emil
foley in the 1982 film an officer and a
gentleman
mayonnaise that role landed him the
academy award
for best supporting actor the first
black american to do so
the one the only mr lou gossey jr
joining us live good morning to you sir
how
are you all right that shrimp and grits
made me hungry
well the next time you're in vegas i'll
make sure my husband saves some for you
too
hey listen boo yeah we're going to get
right into this because i have so many
things to ask you about you have a new
book out right now called an officer and
a gentleman
tell us about that an actor and a
gentleman
yeah an actor and a gentleman and tell
us about that why you decided to write
it obviously a play off the movie
he has to play off the movie and the
life and then the experiences
from from high school all the way until
to the present time
and and it's uh it's it's a it's a
gentle
in inclusive experience good and bad
to explain yourself so you can continue
on so maybe people can understand uh
some of the difficulties that you have
to overcome in order to continue on
and and then that's what uh juneteenth
means is now we can continue on
yeah yeah and i we just showed a cover
of the book it's a beautiful cover there
now i'm going to put you on the spot
here
our arts district uh in downtown las
vegas
we have the jewel of our arts district
it's called the smith center
and they just announced their broadway
series it's happening october 26th
through october 30th
guess what play is going to be part of
the broadway series
hopefully it's a raisin in the sun it's
an officer and a gentleman
lou oh so like i said i'm putting you on
the spot so we want to invite you here
i want your people to call our people so
we can hook you up with the ceo over at
the smith center his name is myron
martin okay we want to see you here
you got it yeah all right now i want to
talk about your latest movie the cuban
i'm gonna be honest with you that movie
was so well done the pace was perfect
the story line
it was so compelling and the end was a
shocker but
the portrayal of your character uh louis
garcia
that kept me so engaged what drew you to
that script
well i was drawn uh because i remember
uh a robert de niro playing character
uh where he in one shot he went from
none none none uh available to being
available
he did it's the explanation of of
alzheimer's disease and that's an
actor's challenge to do stuff that's
difficult i want to
always want the opportunity to do that
so i played this character who
makes this transition from being
non-communicative
to remembering the old days when he was
the star of the copacabana
in in in cuba he was a nightclub star
and he left once castro came into
place and he left he left his family and
his fiancee
and when you see him again he's an
incommunicado in an old age home
yeah what a challenge for an actor to do
that you know yeah it was to allow this
young lady to bring me back to life
it was it was amazing and it seemed like
your role in that movie i mean you've
been doing this a long time it was
effortless
so it was so easy to watch and i was
thinking to myself boy
a lot of young actors in this i would be
so intimidated to have to go on a set
with luke house and junior and play that
role but they did a great job they held
their own
yeah it was great and you know my high
school stuff was afro cuban music
yeah and it was introduced by disney
gillespie who had gone into the latin
countries and brought
a combination of jazz and latin music
together now it's called afro-cuban
and out of that came uh tito puente and
tito rodriguez that was my high school
dance dance competitions for those latin
dances so i got to relive my childhood
yeah and you did it well hey let's talk
about your foundation lou you started it
back in 2006 it is called the
racism foundation talk about perfect
timing tell us all about that
can you hear me lou
can you hear me no we're back no we're
back
we're back okay tell me about your
e-racism foundation
well the racist foundation is it had to
mirror my childhood
and my childhood is where we're
post-depressing children
and in brooklyn and places uh we were
those neighborhoods were filled with
some uh uh intellectual cream of the
crop of europe who were running from
hitler
so they came to the united states they
changed their names and uh they were put
into the new york uh educational system
and and a whole bunch of them came to
brooklyn
and i grew up with their children and
those children turned out to be people
like barbara streisand
wow author miller uh carol king
and uh so we kind of grew up together
with that at that
open attitude and that's where jackie
robinson came for the dodgers and then
jacob jackets and we took very good care
we owned broadway for years
yeah so that when i came to uh be an
actor
and went to a society where that wasn't
happening it was like an ill-fitting
glove so i've been holding that
resentment for quite a while
until i came up with the idea that we
have to get that kind of society back
again we don't have to go broke
we have to lower the walls so we can
live together
the way it's promised in the declaration
of independence one nation under god
indivisible
yeah very injustice so now that's what
that's what uh
our holiday today is you know we need to
be
free loving one another taking care of
one another absolutely i totally agree
yeah that's what the vision is about
well thank you for sharing that with us
i only have less than about 30 seconds
here do you have any other projects
coming up real soon
well i've got the you know you have
foster boys that coming up soon
and i have a podcast as an elder it's
called for what it's worth
okay and i got that from my great
grandmother who
only lied to me one time she said this
is going to hurt me more it's going to
hurt you
all right luke thank you so much we are
out of time we appreciate it and uh
thank you so much for bringing us all of
the wonderful movies and i got to tell
you this is like
coming full circle for me so i'm a kid
who watched roots
you know back in 1977. so far in my
career i have now interviewed four cast
members from that
remarkable movie i have now interviewed
lou gossett jr
ben vereen levar burton and the late
great
cicely tyson wonderful family there
yes it is so thank you so much you've
really
helped me make uh or hit a milestone in
my career i'm very grateful
and i hope to see you in vegas soon come
by and stop by our smith center to see
the play okay
it's only going to cost you one thing
what
shrimp and grits you got it
it's coming all right well take care we
appreciate you so much
all right talk to you later okay all
right bye-bye